I think being the child of a famous
parents I feel for them for that because
they didn't choose that yeah you know
Jennifer Lopez getting candid about her
children's life and the spotlight
everything I do is for them the actress
opens up in a recent interview with
Odyssey that her and ex Marc Anthony's
15 year old twins Max and Emmy are
seeing the effects of Hollywood I think
being the child of famous parents is
really not something that many people
can understand and I and I I feel for
them for that because they didn't choose
that you know and I haven't talked to
them a lot about this they have just
started letting me know like how people
treat them and do things like that so
when they walk into the room that's what
people are thinking about they're not
seeing them for who they are and I think
that that has to be a really hard thing
you go along as an actress and or
performer in this business and it's a
very me me business you know what I mean
my career my things what am I going to
do next what are my choices and when you
have kids it becomes not about you it
becomes about them and what's going to
make them happy and what's going to make
them better and what's going to be
better for them and because they're in
the public eye JLo admits she feels
guilt playing a part in that I did that
to them and so that you know again like
we have this guilt his mom's like what
we do and what we bought into their
lives being judged
um by uh by people that you don't even
know in a way it is I think really
difficult for them to kind of grow up
and be themselves it's just like they
know that there's a lens on them and
that's that's hard but despite it all
Jennifer's got hopes for her teens I
just want them to
be whole healthy loving beings you know
what I mean who stand in their own truth
and
um unapologetically themselves I try to
do that
um and I've tried to do that more as
I've gotten older and grown up a bit and
I want them to you know know that
there's nothing that they can accomplish
that they are very that they are
Limitless that is a real thing if you
believe that you will be able to
accomplish anything in your life and and
I hope that they're getting that from me
foreign